[Music]
on this monday night the world reacts to
russian atrocities
war crimes have taken place the horror
of what happened and the outrage this
guy is brutal what more is the west
willing to do and what's left of the
besieged city of mariopol as a red cross
convoy again fails to get through
now or never we are on a fast track to
climate disaster running out of options
to hit climate goals the latest u.n
report plus connection problems it
deepens the digital divide who's left
out of the plan to make high-speed
internet more affordable
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is hard to put into words the
mounting evidence russian forces are
slaughtering civilians in ukraine the
images emerging are sickening and hard
to look at even ukraine's president who
has seen so much in the 39 days since
russia invaded had trouble taking in the
atrocities in bucha a small city
northwest of kiev the bodies of
civilians shot at close range many with
bound hands or feet scattered on the
streets
these are war crimes vladimir zelinski
says and will be recognized by the world
as genocide as russian soldiers retreat
from ukrainian towns around the capital
and regroup their tactics are being laid
bare
you may remember i got criticized for
calling putin a war criminal
well the truth of the matter to show
what happened to rupert
this warrants him he is a war criminal
there is outrage around the world though
from the kremlin nothing but denials and
even claims the corpses in video footage
are actors participating in a hoax to
discredit russia our coverage tonight
begins with redmond shannon
the pain in butcher is everywhere
this woman spent days searching for her
husband
after two weeks she found him among
bodies in their building's basement
neighbors helped her to dig his grave in
the garden below their home
i recognized him by his shoes she says
he had been shot in the head mutilated
tortured
hers is just one account of possible war
crimes in bucha a small city in the
suburbs of kiev ukrainian authorities
say hundreds of civilians have been
killed here since russian troops were
pushed back
many of the dead found in the street
some with their hands tied this apparent
mass grave on the grounds of a local
church reports emerging from this and
other areas raise serious and disturbing
questions about possible war crimes
president vladimir zelinsky visited
butcher monday
he says his government is aware of
thousands of murders and rapes calling
them more than war crimes he says it's
genocide
says the longer the conflict continues
the more difficult these discoveries
will make peace talks
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
dismissed the video corroborated by
journalists as fake and staged the
kremlin doubling down on misinformation
and denials lavrov claims russian troops
left the bucha area on march 31st but on
that date satellite photos already show
the mass grave has been dug minimalist
on russian state tv one pundit suggested
britain could be involved in staging the
events in bucha
in warsaw a grim warning from ukraine's
foreign minister and i can tell you
without an exaggeration but with great
sorrow that the situation in mario paul
is much worse
compared to what we've seen in buchanan
the mayor of maryupol says his city is
now 90 percent destroyed as russia
shifts focus to the east ukraine says
the kremlin now wants to capture the
second city of harkev and that russia is
looking to mobilize 60 000 extra
reservists redmond shannon global news
london
canada's foreign affairs minister calls
what happened in bucha abhorrent and
senseless melanie jolie is in helsinki
meeting her finnish counterpart
these are clearly war crimes these are
clearly crimes against humanity so yes
there will be more sanctions announced
by canada against uh russian and bella
russian individuals and entities this
will come very soon
we know we have to do more and
we will be doing more
she says canada will target 18 more
russians and bella russians for their
roles in russia's illegal invasion as
jackson proskow reports the question is
how much further is the world willing to
go to push back is there a tipping point
that will trigger military intervention
and another warning some of the content
in his story is disturbing
the images of lifeless bodies and bound
hands may finally force the world to act
to show what happened to rufus
this warrants him he is a war criminal
in washington president joe biden vowed
swift new sanctions and directly called
for prosecution of vladimir putin and
his regime we have to gather the
information we have to continue to
provide ukraine with the weapons they
need to continue the fight
and we have to gather all the detail so
this could be a actual have a war crime
trial across europe more fast moves to
further isolate moscow lithuania told
the russian ambassador to leave
germany and france expelled dozens of
russian diplomats the eu vowed deeper
sanctions after seeing evidence of
atrocities we will advance as a matter
of urgency the work on further sanctions
against kremlin's murderous war
machinery yet ukraine's cries of
genocide have not compelled any country
to change its position on direct
military involvement we have to forget
about half measures
you cannot impose sanctions with your
left hand and trade with russia with
your right hand during a joint
appearance with the ukrainian foreign
minister the british foreign secretary
like many western leaders was reluctant
to put a label on russia's actions now
to the question of genocide that is a
matter for the courts to determine
but what i want to be very clear about
is the uk is taking the maximum approach
we're taking the maximum approach on
sanctions it all leaves open the
question of how far russia must go
before the west steps in
the desire for a negotiated peace may
supersede calls for rapid prosecutions
pragmatically there are people who worry
about pursuing accountability before you
have a peace settlement yet whatever
else is revealed by the russian retreat
may leave the world with no choice but
to take the kind of direct action they
have vowed to avoid
jackson prosko global news washington
a humanitarian convoy has still not been
able to reach the besieged city of
mariupol today the red cross says its
team is being held just west of the city
the convoy has made several failed
attempts to deliver humanitarian aid and
bring people to safety marielleville's
mayor says 130 000 people are still
trapped under dire conditions ukrainian
officials have accused russian troops of
forcibly deporting several thousand
residents to russia
the eu says it is now weighing a full
ban on russian energy imports it is a
sticking point though as some nations
argue their economies are dependent on
russian oil and coal the world's
dependence on fossil fuels is having an
irreversible impact on our climate and
the latest u.n climate report warns
there is little time left for
governments to live up to their
commitments to slash greenhouse gas
emissions the u.n secretary general used
some blunt words today
government and business leaders are
saying one thing but doing another
simply put
they are lying
and the results will be catastrophic
the latest climate report warns the next
few years are critical eric sorenson
reports on the findings and the proposed
solutions
it is a now or never moment to avoid the
worst effects of climate change a major
u.n report describes a litany of
inadequate measures and broken
government promises the empty pledges
that put us firmly on track towards an
unlivable world from 2010 to 2019 total
emissions for all human-caused
greenhouse gases kept rising fossil fuel
and industry with the largest carbon
footprint 64 of emissions the
intergovernmental panel says greenhouse
gases must peak by 2025 and be reduced
by almost 45 percent by 2030 to limit
global warming to the target of 1.5
degrees celsius
the impacts are everywhere heat waves
and wildfires extreme storms and floods
melting ice and permafrost and rising
sea levels british columbia alone was
whiplashed by blistering heat and
torrential rains and floods last year
climate advocates say canada is a major
culprit supporting fossil fuel
production we have contributed massively
to
over-consumption
over-exploitation of resources and for a
country as wealthy as canada i think we
need to look ourselves in the mirror
ottawa suggests this country's energy
production cannot be business as usual
it only reinforces the urgent
requirement for energy sector in every
region and every jurisdiction to speed
up the decarbonization of our economies
one hopeful development clean energy is
becoming more affordable every year the
un reports as unit costs have fallen
dramatically since 2010 85 for solar
energy 55 percent for wind and 85 for
electric batteries
but the dilemma is what to do in the
short term there's a need for oil and
gas right now a shortage made worse by
the war in ukraine there's benefits to
diversifying our energy supply by
building more of these new clean energy
projects but the real challenge is well
but do we keep building all these uh all
these fossil fuel projects this month
ottawa will decide on a major oil
project off the coast of newfoundland
and labrador which will send a strong
signal one way or the other about
canada's approach to energy and climate
change eric sorensen global news toronto
british columbia's premier john horgan
revealed today he's tested positive for
covid19 in a tweet oregon said his
symptoms are mild thanks to being fully
vaccinated the 62 year old recently
underwent treatment for throat cancer he
is one of thousands of canadians finding
themselves with covid right now as the
latest variant spreads hospital and icu
admissions are beginning to creep up at
the same time testing has stopped mass
mandates have dropped and vaccine uptake
has slowed now the world health
organization is warning of a new even
more transmissible recombinant strain
called xe
jamie morocco explains what all this
means for you
frontline health workers are growing
frustrated watching covet infection
rates rise while more masks come off we
removed precautions at the very worst
time as a new wave is about to start a
lost layer of protection as another
means stalls just 47 of canadians have
had a booster dose we need to get rid of
this idea that being fully or adequately
vaccinated is anything less than three
that's wrong so if you are not a three
you are not adequately vaccinated the
federal government still considers a
double dose fully vaccinated with no
plans to make a change officials are
mulling recommendations for fourth doses
for those over 50.
experts are also hanging hopes on strain
specific vaccines seeing success in
clinical trials going forward
this is going to be tied really closely
to
pathogen surveillance
instead of relying on pcr testing
provinces are tracking wastewater as
well as hospital and icu numbers it
revealed omicron's subvariant ba2 is on
the rise but severity of illness isn't
so far other countries have seen similar
trends but they're showing covid isn't
latent the who is now warning of a new
strain out of the uk
xe a recombination of omicron's ba1 and
ba2 subvariants it's believed to be 10
percent more transmissible than ba2
which is causing the latest surge
because we're giving
kovitt a chance for this to happen
the ball is no longer in our court the
ball's down the viruses court this is
kind of a do-it-yourself pandemic if you
have any symptoms
stay away and protect other people more
reason to stay vigilant keep masks on
and minimize spread jamie morocco global
news toronto
in hong kong cases of kovit 19 are
finally beginning to decline after the
worst wave of covet 19 there the
territory's leader kerry lam has been
widely criticized for her handling of
the pandemic and today she said she
won't seek reelection lamb says she's
stepping down in order to spend more
time with family her five-year term as
chief executive has been tumultuous
there were city-wide protests in 2019
over an extradition bill with mainland
china that led beijing to implement a
national security law that cracked down
on democratic opposition and her
decision to follow china's strict zero
code policy has dealt a blow to hong
kong's economy
lowering the cost of high-speed internet
coming up who's eligible for ottawa's
cheaper plan to access the web
[Music]
elon musk has plenty of followers on
twitter and now he is also the company's
largest shareholder the tesla and spacex
founder bought 9.2 percent of the social
media site last month a stake valued at
nearly 3 billion dollars u.s the world's
richest man is no stranger to the
platform of course he has more than 80
million followers and he has a tendency
to tweet some controversial sometimes
inflammatory things last week for
example he raised questions about free
speech on the site and he tweeted he was
giving serious thought to creating a
whole new platform
during the isolation of the pandemic
home internet became a lifeline for many
and more and more seniors in particular
logging on for the first time but with
the high cost of connecting it's not
something every canadian can afford as
abigail beeman reports the federal
government is taking another step
towards its commitment to get everyone
online with high-speed internet by 2030.
stephanie graham and her husband rely on
the internet for everything from zooming
grandchildren to making medical
appointments my husband just got out of
the hospital in december he nearly lost
his leg
and the only way we could get
appointments with doctors is by the
internet all of the doctors are asking
for internet they earn less than 40
grand a year and are disappointed they
don't qualify for the newly expanded
affordable internet program well for one
thing i could get my bottom teeth fixed
connecting families 2.0 is now for
low-income families and seniors who
receive either the maximum canada child
benefit or the maximum guaranteed income
supplement at twenty dollars a month the
government is promising internet speeds
5 and 10 times faster than the previous
10 plan which people can still access if
they wish data doubles to 200 gigabytes
per month
14 internet service providers are on
board we frequently hear that people in
canada pay some of the highest prices in
the world for internet and cell phone
connectivity advocacy groups applaud the
move but are calling for expansions to
the eligibility list and the data limit
for the internet of 2022 that simply
isn't enough it deepens the digital
divide we would certainly like to see
this expanded to anyone who qualifies
for the gis at all
and of course on a go forward basis to
make sure that the quality of the
internet that they're getting is also
going to be
good experts say the number of seniors
who qualify is not big and exactly how
many people will be helped is not clear
anyone eligible will be sent a letter
those letters have already gone out but
the government isn't saying how many
were issued abigail beeman global news
ottawa
bracing for the federal budget ahead the
potential billions in new spending
you're watching global national
deputy prime minister and finance
minister christopher freeland is putting
the finishing touches on the latest
federal budget it is set to be delivered
on thursday with plenty of demands for
new spending and investments in
everything from housing to dental care
to defense david aiken looks at what's
going into the equation of the upcoming
budget
10 a day child care right across the
country
this week's budget got its start on last
summer's campaign trail with a liberal
election platform stuffed with 50
billion dollars in new spending promises
our government was re-elected on a
commitment to grow our economy
make life more affordable and to
continue building a canada where nobody
gets left behind but since then a deal
with jug meat sings ndp to implement a
national pharmacare and national dental
care program price tag could eventually
be 13 billion dollars a year for dental
care we are looking for
enough funding to
phase in phase one of the plan which is
for all children under 12 who don't have
coverage you need it most and that we're
we're fairly confident will be in the
budget plus a war in ukraine bringing
renewed pressure on canada to boost
defense spending to the nato target of
two percent of gdp for canada to do that
freeland must find another 20 billion
dollars a year and then there's
provincial governments continuing to
push for billions more in annual federal
health transfers i don't envy the
government but they've got to squeeze
that much in political commitments into
a really small space and remain fiscally
sustainable without increasing taxes now
high oil prices and better than expected
economic growth have given ottawa what
forecasters say could be an extra seven
to thirteen billion dollars in revenue
and that is extra money freeland will
definitely need donna okay david aiken
in ottawa thank you
war crimes being documented as they
unfold next the impact of the brutality
in bucha
there are some things we should never
get used to seeing those things are
unfolding in ukraine right now vladimir
putin has said ukraine as a nation does
not exist that the land belongs to
russia and those who get in the way of
that plan including civilians including
women and children are being killed
evidence of war crimes is mounting and
being compiled in real time
mike armstrong reports and a warning
some of the video is difficult to watch
it is still very early in the process
but researchers investigating possible
war crimes in bucha are already finding
evidence that points to something
horrible bodies that are being recovered
are having to have their hands unbound
we have a number of people
who
appear to have been killed with their
hands bound behind their backs using
plastic zip ties
at the local church no one knows exactly
how many bodies are in the fresh mass
graves there is however a count from one
day march 10th the priest says at least
68 bodies were collected from around
town on that day
and buried
here he says people were killed trying
to leave and their bodies were in the
streets they couldn't take them to the
cemetery going there was too dangerous
the town's mayor says any war is a crime
but they're still supposed to be rules
the way his citizens were treated was
something else
soldiers were deliberately killing
civilians and that the only way he can
describe it is genocide
that same word was used by ukraine's
president monday as he visited bucha
vladimir zolensky says walking the
streets understanding what happened
makes negotiating with the russian side
tougher
zalenski says they're finding bodies in
barrels and basements tortured and
executed war crimes one after another
there are unimaginable scenes in just
about every direction bodies on highways
in this case a family buried together at
least partially according to locals it
was the head of the village with her son
and husband they would have been killed
by russian soldiers who believe they
were helping ukrainian
troops investigators have a great deal
of work ahead of them
mike armstrong global news
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with some sound and reflection
from a ukrainian musician
[Music]
his name is mark demianchenko he took
his guitar to the rubble of harkeev
where he lives one of the many once
vibrant places in ukraine now reduced to
a shadow of what it once was
we wish peace to everyone the 20 year
old says because without peace life is
very difficult
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you